game pass everybody and i have been
looking forward to this game for what
feels like a very long time it might not
have even been that long it's just that
my hype is palpable um i did play the
opening cut scene and then was like whoa
wait i should be recording this so for
context that's all i've played so we're
gonna go new game
um
and yeah i've been looking forward to a
really for a really long time it's like
a very cute zelda-esque
uh looking thing that i guess
this is further than i got when i first
hit
uk
and i'm already in love i'm already in
love
okay i'm gonna move the webcam because
i'm covering some stuff
i go up here that should be okay or
maybe i'll put myself down in the corner
hang on give me a second give me a
second give me a second
that should work all right
i don't want to cover the
red and green
ah
stamina i see
truly the dark souls of boss
and the other one's gonna be health that
is the oh
oh whoa okay that's interesting
xyb i don't have anything equipped
it's the only thing that i can do right
now really is roll
cute roll animation though
how nice is this music
okay
all right
nothing yet
is there a sprint
that's sprinting no i think it's just
just a steady pace a mailbox
okay
we're gonna go inside the mysterious
house
all right i don't have a weapon yet
though
surely there'll be a master sword right
here waiting for me next to all these
pots surely
not quite
thank you for my first achievement i
appreciate that for the stick
okay
yep
stick yes
aha okay let's put it to
x i think
that seems right
i said it immediately gives you the
option actually that's a cool touch
okay let's go beat some blobs with my
stick
nice i don't know my head really worked
to make that an innuendo
maybe it didn't work
oh how nice is this music okay i wonder
how important the lock on actually is
okay
i feel like this will be easy it's gonna
be fine barely took any damage no i
think this game is probably gonna be
pretty challenging uh okay lock on is
important
um all right
okay
not bad
heroes grave
link
i love this this style
it's also giving me death's door vibes
which um
if you did not play it was one of my
games of the year last year i really
really loved it published by devolver
digital
made by a very small team
i thought it was fantastic
i'm assuming i can't get past these
blocks right now
don't break them can't roll no okay
i could be missing stuff but i'm not
gonna let myself get caught up in the
anxiety of
i am a very big fan of what this is
doing for oh that healed me it's a
shrine
ah
it's grace interesting um in terms of
tutorialization right now in that it is
doing
all the enemies came back okay
people hate dark souls comparisons but
if the shoot fits
yeah what did i just agree to
[Music]
um
yes very big fan of of what it's doing
for the tutorialization right now that's
a thing that like i like so many games
get so wrong
is treating players like they're idiots
um
[Music]
like you could give somebody who's never
played a game before
a controller
and i don't think you have to expect
that that they
have that literacy to know certain
things are up and down all the time when
um
in a lot of instances if you're left
with a controller in your hands you're
gonna press all the buttons to figure
out what does what and that's that's a
fun part of the experience
but also letting me choose which which
button to
make attack okay
i wonder if i only have a certain amount
of those though and that i just wasted
one of them i don't know it said hero's
grave it sounded exciting
ooh
[Music]
interesting this is going to be like a
little
suggestion of what i should do i need to
get a light for the dark tune that's
three pokemon
well
that's your actual like tutorial
magic points i don't have any magic yet
everything hurts way more when i'm tired
oh my gosh this is so cute
oh my god
i'm in love this game is already
my favorite
wow okay
so i guess your your hits hit harder
when you're stabbing his leg that's a
different way to approach that
somebody already open that chest
who else ventures out here
how dare you
hmm
i guess we'll see
nothing okay
you gotta go oh you can't go down no
okay i guess there's gonna be something
at some point that lets me open those um
we'll break those blocks
[Music]
okay i don't think i went out this way
last time not that it'll make a huge
difference
it's another shrine
damn
i'm so curious
the locked off areas really get you okay
what's this way
oh that's right i can't go there anyway
yeah
and then we will go back to the town or
is it blocked off yeah i think i just
doubled back because i found the key so
let's go back this way
maybe it is blocked off
it is okay never mind
i will find another way around
unless i just miss something it's
entirely possible
i'm liking these big boxes with swords
they're cool
[Music]
[Music]
dude
this music
nothing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry if i'm being overly quiet i'm just
very
into what i'm experiencing right now
how wondrous
hmm
i wondered
how far are you gonna let me go
[Music]
what the heck is this gonna be where i
get my magic maybe
oh that's one of the foxes
ah it's princess zelda i see i see i see
i'm familiar with what you're doing
i get it man she looks cute you know
what she looks cute i understand
um
no magic
okay
has anything changed
that is a nerve
assume i can't go into the water
uh
was there somewhere else to go around
here that i just missed probably
i'm very bad at directional stuff
also i was pressing the wrong button
this print this whole time i imagine
it's not gonna let me go in there again
seal forever
dude huge bummer what about the hot
chick
from a fox's perspective
can't do that okay
i definitely can't go anywhere this way
oh i wonder if i can
what the
oh
wow
i see you environment
cool this is my first dungeon
a mini dungeon of sorts
nothing okay
i want it
i would like it very much
excuse me hello
all right i'm gonna have to find someone
else to unlock that is my guess
yeah very big fan of of uh like i said
the quote-unquote tutorialization
this game is really just throwing me
into it being like figure it out [ __ ]
and i love that
ah
of course i love those
zubats even here
i can't get rid of them
i don't know if i can block
oh i didn't mean to do that that was me
hitting lb like if i was trying to parry
no okay that's what the shield's gonna
be for it makes sense
i cannot block yet
but soon
also am i getting xp i don't actually
know i didn't check
oops
don't mean to do that walk right nobody
saw anything pretend i edited that out
very if it was really good cut none of
you saw it it was like a really stealthy
edit
doc oh no no no we're not ready for this
yet
no i'm leaving i take it back i'm
leaving
i apologize have a good night
this is a wrong turn my bad
peace be with you
okay big boy
i would really like to be able to parry
is all i'm saying
oh i'm out of stamina run away little
fox
oh he's tough
this may not end well for me
i'm having trouble getting past that
sword i mean the the shield
and the distance away is tough okay
please sir
ah
i was facing the wrong direction
okay it's fine it's fine
we learning would love a parry would
love for perry
is this just a loading screen
or is this supposed to happen
i'm sorry hot fox lady
i was a huge fan of you in space jam
technically she's not a fox she's a
bunny but you know
do furries have like like sub topics
like is it like are you just really into
a wolf
what do they kind of like mix and match
asking the real questions
resurrected
look at me go
okay we're gonna try again
i don't remember where i went though
what's up
all right
he's here he was here okay
but
i will say
the um
controls are fighting with me a little
bit it's not too bad
but there
you just do kind of get stuck on the
environment a tiny bit
you guys gonna spawn again
hey forgot about that range
okay nice
that did so much damage though too man
souls
i haven't even really looked at like
xp yet
obvi doesn't do anything
i could try him again
[Music]
no
i will not try him again
so you gonna chase me
i don't think so
[Music]
okay
great
[Music]
what is that
okay nowhere to go from here
let's go back down
is there a parry that i'm just missing
was i supposed to be able to open that
gate and i just couldn't i don't know
um did i move when my weapon was
equipped to was it always b
wasn't an x earlier
is that what
did i do that
i'm confused
hang on i think that i accidentally
remapped my weapon while in that menu
that's my bad
um i just feel like maybe i'm supposed
to have the shield by now
sorry just temporarily pause because i
got a phone call okay
um
so i suspect that i probably wasn't
supposed to go that way
let's see if there is somewhere else for
me to go
this just says town and i think we're
supposed to go to the town yet because
like these seem like enemies that i
should be fighting i don't think i'm
ready for sword guy
the shield guy until i get a shield it's
just what i'm suspecting
i go through here
let's just scope out
what else there is that maybe i missed
[Music]
maybe
no
i've already tried this isn't gonna be
it
[Music]
oh no okay we probably can't get further
from here maybe did i just go down or
maybe i didn't go up
it's entirely possible
um let's go up
of course yes thank you for pointing
that out appreciate it
some parts to break
yeah see these enemies just feel more my
level and i think that maybe
i was getting a bit ahead of myself with
how hectic that got back there
um
because i think that the
the manual also listed dark cave is like
pretty far down
i don't know how to open it up again but
there was um
instruction booklet
so this is
that's page 11.
page 10 right so it says ringing the
east bell east forest so i'm thinking i
go to east forest first i've already
done hero's grave
[Music]
i haven't done god captain
then west bella's old house the dark
tomb that's in the other direction and
that's page 29 that's ages away so i
think
right now we look for
east forest is what i'm thinking
ah
there it is that worked out
i do want to say i really like the music
i feel like a little bit like maybe i
guess that's an opening area
in that section i feel like it didn't
necessarily like really suit
what i was doing if that makes sense
okay i see the stamina bod doesn't go
down while you're hitting only while
you're running but i think it stays the
same it won't go up either
okay
oh controls
oh d i want it so bad oh health shields
i want all of it so bad important
stamina points great
wait wait let me read two pages there no
no no let me just read it oh no that's
for the other one
that we've done beginning your adventure
then we go this way
phase roll
all this run yep cool that's so cute i
love the style
all right
s1 does
i'm gonna come up here
or maybe we go down there first
it's giving me that like gamer anxiety
where i just want to go across all of
the parts okay thankfully that looks
like a dead end so we are coming back
down
let's do it
oh hello friend
hey little cheeky fella
down here
who opened that chest i'm the
protagonist the chest are mine how dare
you
how dare you take this this moment away
from me
zero out of ten
the east forest see i'm just feeling
like maybe these enemies are more my
style i love this animation the way
these move
all right
oh well
i probably need something for it they
look like little um oris
i'm gonna have me beat up ari
in a forest
xbox is really up to some stuff huh
yeah
the other way was definitely the wrong
way to go it was just too much heat man
it's just too much heat
i'm not ready to face sword boy without
sword
pick your battles you know
especially when you just have a stick
that's words to live by pick your
battles especially when you just have a
stick
hero's grave oh didn't i already go to
your screen maybe there are multiple
[Music]
guard house one okay
is this one
is it telling is the exclamation point
telling me that they're alerted or that
they're attacking i wonder big fan of
the tutorialization love to figure it
out
that looks like it's a plot of some kind
not for me
hey [ __ ]
a huge fan of your games
okay
can we go over this way no
this game's doing a really good job of
teasing things
somewhat
metroidvania esque level design you
would think
all right here is grave what if can you
imagine if heroes grave had a sword
that should be pretty sick
okay
yeah
no
moment of safety
oh
you have an invulnerability period while
you're rolling
you can always attack even without
stamina stability flinch knocked over
interesting
cool okay that's interesting um all
right keep moving
you put that here oh you are lodged
and there are two of you i don't feel
good about it but the like shrine not
shrine is right there so
nope we need stamina back excuse me
fellas
oh i'm like stuck
i thought that i'd be able to run
forward but it didn't let me
okay
the boys are big
just gonna keep moseying for now
what is this
hero's grave i mean that's where it
wants me to go
let's follow the signs and then we'll
come back here
when we have a sword hopefully you can
hold me out for it pop the hero's grave
great
oh hello big
big chonco with a frowny face oh my
it's a sick flip you guys can do damn
damn no no
no you don't
i want potions so bad okay
you can do ranged attacks
no
that's all right it's not very far back
and i think that i think we're probably
on the right path we're going to keep
going a hero's grave
nope no oh well
scope it out
how how easily i changed my mind
guard house 2. can i fit through there
alas i cannot how about around here no
okay
never mind
does this go anywhere no
all right let's keep going a hero's
grave
me and my stick
yeah i think i sort of feel similarly
about the music here it's beautiful and
it's like this is music that i would
like love to fall asleep to
so how does what you tell my friend how
do i know you're about to attack
it's just purple
keep thinking because they're not facing
me
that i'm not gonna get hit
it's smart it's smart
um
yeah this is the kind of music that i
would love to fall asleep to but i don't
know that it necessarily suits what i'm
doing ooh souls
that hurt him
i like the noise they make that
i like little cats
alrighty
take you out real quick
yeah you can't interrupt them
definitely worth noting um okay keep
going
and another one
big boy
too mean
okay
hello good sir
all right it's the flash purple
i think that maybe i shouldn't
not yet you know just not yet you're too
big to get up
suck it punk
today is not your day
okay yeah yes
very strong for such a small fox that's
gonna open that gate neat okay
hey bud
you still have a lot more health than i
do my friend
oh
can you use enemies to break blocks
[Music]
that's interesting
this is what i want this is what i'm
here for give me the sword
yes
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
okay so we're going to do that and we're
going to go
nope stop doing that alana oh i bet i'm
about to go god mode i can break these
now that was very quick
i mean
i don't know why i thought i was
invincible when i had like effectively
one health that was on me do i still
have my sword i do okay
things are gonna play out differently
now
very exciting
let's do it
bravo my pee
i'm sick
oh my god i'm a tank
ah that's gonna open up so much of the
world so fast that's really neat
i don't even probably need to go back
here i guess i just wanted to
avenge myself
get absolutely wrecked you absolute
scrub
give me my souls back
i like that uh getting them back
actually knocks people away from you i
guess it's probably designed to like be
able to give you a shot you know
um
so is that marked off in my booklet now
that's the wrong way
no
but i have been here
also i don't even know what the level
system is
like should i be caring about souls
ah
who knows
maybe i'll find somewhere to purchase
stuff from oh my god
i'm like so excited about how quickly
things just opened up because the sword
can cut through
the i don't know hedges
that's so neat um
all right let's go up
well we could also rest
because why not
i'm very into this very very into this
really really
love the way that this is unfolding
again
i want to give a huge shout out to
death's door another game that i really
enjoyed
it has a very similar vibe
just
a cool looking guy over there
look at him
there's a mage of some kind neat
all right
do a stealth
attack sorta
okay
hello sir
ready to kick your butt
not great peripheral vision you should
probably see an optometrist about that
[Music]
nice yep okay
i wonder how long this game is
because if you tell me it's 100 hours
i'm gonna be real sad if this is like a
short
give me like a 10 hours of this i'm
gonna be so
happy god house one this is the first
place on my list
okay
is that a chest it is
thank you still don't know what these
things do but i will take them
oh i love that
oh that's cool okay i'm gonna go through
here first though
or i could just stay where i am for now
maybe not yet
oh this is that i was in this room
before
i've already been here
i probably should have gone up there
then huh
i probably should go to take out the god
damn it
damn it
he just looks so big and i am so small
and so cute
i don't wanna
[Music]
might not be that bad
oh he's slow so this actually might be
fine
oof that one got me
okay it was okay
i was very nervous about nothing
all right
great news great news fox actually open
finally
this is living
don't mind if i do
i'm just hoping that they come back at
the fires
otherwise i sort of wasted it probably
didn't need it that bad
whatever i'll take it
all right
felt a bit nervous about that
i made it
[Music]
that makes sense he's giving me
instructions
cool
damn we gaming out here
okay so now if i go back to my
instruction booklet
there are never any ticks so
i've done as far as heroes grave and
guard captain now i need to go
the other way oh there's gonna be a rope
to come oh look how metroidvania you are
dude i love this game
i'm vibing with this real hard
okay
and now i one hit these little guys
you didn't know what was coming you saw
me you saw me leaving and you were like
you just got a stick it it's gonna be
fine
not anymore
look at me now ow i don't remember what
was up so we're gonna go check this
first
this bit right here nothing
or is it
it really looks like
i find secret secrets
great
i love that too
okay
hmm
that thing that i just got does it maybe
do something
no
i don't think there's anywhere for me to
go from here
i think it's just teasing me again
all right hey i open the chest
one step at a time baby
okay
the way his ears bounce when he runs oh
my god
am i being pandered too
and now there's a shotgun
excellent
big fan of this design
this is going to be another instruction
note up here i'll come grab this
won't let me
guess because there's hostiles nearby
hello my friends
my little aries
get out of here
it's pretty lazy with that one but it's
fine
i can't take it
there we go okay
i see
so old house is where it wanted me to go
next
okay
bringing the west bellows my next okay
great
i love these style i mean it's just nice
that like they didn't
no part of this game is like pretending
to not be inspired by zelda
you know
you just went for it
all the retro
little guides yeah big fans all very
very cool
thank you don't mind if i do
okay
the house
might be that not positive though let's
go
mess these twos up first yeah i do have
like a little bit of trouble clipping on
stuff that's all i'll say
hello angry man
what you got to be mad about you are
like living in this beautiful place it's
a sunny day always apparently
and yet we're not in a drought
check your privilege
privilege we started on
on that one that's all i'm saying should
check your goddamn privilege
friend
shopkeeper
nope
nusa
[Music]
great question let's run into it
[Music]
ah
it is a shopkeeper
i'll take the dynamite thank you big boy
you have anything else
[Music]
dude i love him
i love him loving my life he's
incredible
that's that that was awesome okay i'll
come back with more money for you
i would die to please you
further this way
yeah i remember these parts okay
let's go down
all right
[ __ ] you up
this range one's got me a bit
it'll happen
i hope that i can upgrade my stamina a
little bit somewhere
that would be real nice hey rude
i keep wanting to run backwards but i
can't
and i'm also finding that uh the target
lock is not always necessarily that
useful it is when there's one of them
but not when there's multiple
i don't have one yet
damn it
i am next to the old house great
[Music]
that is what i thought just gonna keep
exploring for a second don't mind me
objective
don't mind me
get out of my face glad i saw this
all right well i just bought a whole
bunch of that which now feels like a
waste but it's fine
think those are hot containers maybe
is this open
not yet okay let's go to the house
ah it's still locked
[Music]
maybe it just wanted me in this
direction
i do not know
what the hell
who taught you how to do that since when
you've been pulling moves like that
[Music]
it's got a shield it's got a shield
it's just i just don't know what range
to be
away from them did not get hit
just got to play it slow i guess okay
let me check what this is
[Music]
next we've ever left some of this over
okay another flower
nice
okay getting a lot of dynamite there's
gonna be a reason for it huh
final part final pot let's go
[Music]
[Music]
big sword boy
i think the hitbox is
clear enough
yeah it's okay it's not that bad you can
kind of scope it out ooh i am low on
health though
jerk
did i not just heal
oh my god
this is stressing me out you know what
you can just go it's fine we don't need
to hang out
he's got to be so close
i'm so curious about the guy down below
no no no not now
not right now
i don't
have the health for this [ __ ]
leave me alone oh i'm just on the other
side of this that's not that helpful oh
oh
you truly hate to see it i wonder if
that stayed open
it would be like right here wouldn't it
i should just go for it i shouldn't why
did i even get involved in this race
wait what fall it uses stamina
didn't even know i did it ah
yeah look at me go good timing on
that all right fine fine
it's a bit hot hey that was through a
door
come on now
all my homies explode into
dust so i feel like i'm not really
following the guide right now because
i'm not really at the old house but
i need a key for it so
one step at a time i'm scared of that
dude much as i think he is extremely
cool i am scared of the rat i guess it's
a rat
not today mate not today
and how do i get to that piece of paper
i wonder
punk
there's two dudes with swords out here
man
i don't want anything to do with it can
i open this right now no
you can't spam them good to know
[Music]
he's going to be a bit harder because
he's going to see me keep moving
find out what's up with rat boy
ah you have the key
noted
all right hello there
very nervous
no oh god
okay
um we're gonna
and then we're gonna
we're gonna why
i killed myself
i should have thought that they would do
that
but
i feel good about strategy
i used so many oh gosh okay my bad my
bad
it's fine it's fine
i really should have known
everybody i went the wrong way everybody
leave me alone not right now not right
now
this way
i just get out of my face not right now
i'm trying to go beat the rat king
oh you're all just gonna chase me
all of you every single one of you
i don't love that for me
no
oh
okay okay oh god oh god it's the vibe so
bad
him
um okay
[Music]
that's gonna do it
and we have key
beautiful
oh it literally is the old house key i
was wondering if maybe there were
different keys for different
sorry if it was the same key for every
location but
this is cute
she just made me a little bit motion
sick funnily enough
okay
no
yeah it's the only like consistent issue
i'm having is
sometimes walking into things that i
don't want to be walking into
back to the old house everybody leave me
alone
i have no quarrel with any of you you're
all fine folk
except for you
who i very specifically have borrow with
get out of my face thank you sir
house let's do it
okay
i don't know what's in here
[Music]
do you mean it's my old house
oh my gosh
just one
what
[Music]
maybe it is
i have been seeing this
it's finally here
oh my god yes
because i didn't want to go back to that
other area without a shield
um oh it's auto equipped
auto equipped okay let's see what
parry's like before we stop playing
shall we
i already go through that i don't
remember um okay nope
not quite
i want to check how far through we are
too
it's this way
flooded well we haven't done flooded
well
that's just why the shopkeeper is
probably right
this is definitely just chapter one um
trying to see if the map has flooded
well on it old house sealed temple dark
tomb
well there it is it's just above old
house okay let's go
that maybe is just where
you
i'm not on the right path right now i
need to go back down
is that is that where i made the
purchases from maybe
i'll just come back around this way
or not
unsure
that i wouldn't say that was a flooded
well
thinking i'm thinking it's that
[Music]
something over there
it's already been in here let's just
check them out see if that's what it is
yeah okay so i do have to go that full
loop around
all right time to test out my shield
this way
[Music]
really burn through those bombs my god
it's a lot faster now okay i need to
practice the rt as well
make sure we hit it
it's a little slow-mo thing i was just
doing
didn't need to use it
that's all right
oh
a chili
danger
i live for that
hey little guy
press lt instead of rt my bad
and that time i was too slow
oh great
like staggers them
oh that's awesome
um this might be tough though i have so
little help
something like shoot missiles at me
before
that's what i'm worried about
there it is there it is
oh i can probably block them with a
shield i can probably block them with
the shield
okay
attempt to block with shield
let's go
who do you guys think you are no you're
supposed to be dead by now thank you
okay
this old jerk
smack the bejesus out of him
[Music]
all right
maybe i take the potion before we go in
yeah okay
okay
oh i've walked under the wrong place
okay that does work oh god
not two of you i can't take two of you
why did it stop why did it stop oh [ __ ]
oh god oh god no no no
oh man
why is that even there oh i got my
stamina down wait wait oh my god
i'm still alive i thought i was dead
[ __ ]
i think that can work
we just have to get closer
there
did that work
oh it did
oh my god
okay that was a lot can i knock this
down
no
[Music]
jesus christ [ __ ] that guy
how do i get there there's a lot going
on here that i don't know what to do
with thank you
can't get over there
oh
i just have to wait for the correct
prompt
that makes sense oh cute okay
this is gonna be the well
okay
oh
good to know
good to know okay cool
shield bomb bomb bomb three types of
bombs fruit hot pepper
interesting golden coin
i love the way it's giving out
information it's so
it's just so alluring you know
oh man i really kicked my butt i hope
there's another shrine down here that'd
be real nice
beneath the well
please don't kill me
just oh not right now just give me a
minute you know
oh okay oh
i don't know you could do that
tried
anybody seen a shrine
is the water gonna hurt me ah
no
alrighty i think we are at an hour so
i'm gonna call it that thank you guys so
much for watching i really like this
game i'm super into it obviously still
have a lot to learn
and i am playing at 3am which is not my
finest work um i like it a lot yeah
thank you guys for watching i hope you
enjoyed the first hour of gameplay of
tunic i might stream some more of it
because i'm super into it so far and
that is it for me today everyone i'll
see you guys next time bye